i want to start off with talking to you
about three things that keep me up at
night right three things
the first and it may be you know very
common for you too is climate change
climate change absolutely keeps me up at
night
the second thing that keeps me up at
night is that
people may have no idea that an
artificial intelligence is making a
decision that directly impacts their
lives
what percentage interest rate you get on
your loan
whether you get that job that you
applied for
whether your kid gets into that college
that they really want to go to
today ai is making decisions that
directly impact you
the third thing
that keeps me up at night is
even when people know
that an ai is making a decision about
them
they may assume that because it's not a
fallible human with bias
that somehow
the ai is going to make a decision
that's morally or ethically squeaky
clean and that could not be farther from
the truth so
if you think about organizations and
what happens
over 80 percent of the time
proof of concepts associated with
artificial intelligence actually gets
stalled in testing and more often than
not it is because people do not trust
the results
from that ai model so we're going to
talk a lot about trust and when thinking
about trust i'm going to switch colors
here
there's actually five
pillars
okay when you're thinking about what
does it take to earn trust in an
artificial intelligence that's being
made
by your organization or being procured
by your organization five pillars
the first thing to be thinking about is
fairness
how can you ensure
that the ai model
is fair towards everybody in particular
historically underrepresented groups
okay
the second is
explainable
is your ai model explainable such that
you'd be able to tell somebody an end
user
what data sets were being used in order
to curate that model what methods what
expertise was the data lineage in
provenance associated with how that
model was trained
the third
robustness
can you assure end users that
nobody can hack such an ai model such
that
a person could disadvantage willfully
other people
and or
make the result of that model benefit
one particular person over another
the fourth is transparency
are you telling people right off the bat
that the ai model is indeed being used
to make that decision and are you giving
people access to a fact sheet or
metadata so that they can learn more
about that model
and the fifth one is are you assuring
people's data privacy so those are the
five pillars okay
now ibm
has come up with three principles
when thinking about ai in an
organization
the first being that the purpose of
artificial intelligence is really meant
to be to augment human intelligence
not to replace it
the second is that data
and the insights from those data belong
to the creator alone okay and the third
is that ai systems and i would opine
the entire ai life cycle
really should be transparent and
explainable right so so those are the
five pillars now the next thing i want
you to remember
as you're thinking about this space of
earning trust and artificial
intelligence is that this is not a
technological challenge it can't be
solved with just throwing tools and tech
over some kind of offense this is a
socio-technological challenge social
meaning people people people
socio-technological challenges because
it's a socio-technological challenge
it must be addressed holistically
okay holistically
meaning there's three major things that
you should think about i mentioned
people
people the culture of your organization
right thinking about the diversity of
your teams you know your data science
team who is curating that data to train
that model how many women are on that
team
how many minorities are on that team
right think about diversity i don't know
if you've ever heard
of the the wisdom of crowns that's
actually a proven mathematical theory
the more diverse your group of people
the less chance for error and that is
absolutely true in the realm of
artificial intelligence the second thing
is process or governance right what is
it that use your organization what are
you going to promise your both your
employees as well as the market with
respect to what standards you're going
to stand by for your ai model in terms
of things like fairness and
explainability accountability etc right
and the third area
is tooling right
what are
the tools
ai engineering methods frameworks that
you can use in order to ensure these
things ensure those five pillars and
we're going to do a deep dive into that
as well but the next show
that i'm going to be running with you
we're actually going to be talking about
this one about people and culture so
stay tuned
if you like this video and series please
comment below
stay tuned for more videos that are part
of this series and to get updates please
like and subscribe